There's this idea in union psychology
called the circumambulation and you only
had this idea that you had a potential
future self which would be in potential
everything that you could be and that
it manifests itself moment to moment in
your present life by making you interested
in things and the things that you're
interested in are the things that would
guide you along the path that would lead
you to maximal development.
Now it sounds like a metaphysical
idea or a or a mystical idea even,
but,
but it's not.
It's,
it's not.
It's a really profoundly biological idea.
The idea is something like,
well,
you're set up so that you're automatically
interested in those things that was
fully expand you as a well
adapted creature while like
there's nothing radical
about that idea.
How else,
what else could possibly be the case
unless there's something fundamentally
flawed about you.
That is what the situation would be.
It's kind of interesting to think about
how that would be manifest moment to
moment,
but the idea is something like,
well,
your interest is captured by those
things that lead you down the path of
development.
Well that better be the case.
Okay.
So that's fine.
And so there's some utility in pursuing
those things that you're interested in.
That's the call to adventure,
let's say.
So.
And the call to adventure
takes you all sorts of places.
Now the problem with the
call to adventure is like,
what the hell do you know?
You might be interested in things
that are kind of warped and bent.
And often it's the case that when new
parts of people manifest themselves and
gripped their interest,
say they do it very badly in shoddily.
And so you stumble around like an
idiot when you try to do something new.
That's where the fool is the
precursor to the savior from the,
from the symbolic perspectives.
Cause you have to be a fool
before you can be a master.
And if you're not willing to be
a fool and you can't be a master,
so,
so you're going to,
it's,
it's an error,
error ridden process.
And that's also laid out in the old
testament stories because the first thing
that happens to all these patriarchal
figures when God kicks them out of their
father's house when they're
like 84 is that they,
they run into all sorts of trouble.
And some of it's social and some of it's
natural and some of it's a consequence
of their own moral inadequacy.
So they're fools and,
but,
but the thing that's so interesting is
that despite the fact that they're fools,
they're still supposed to go on the
adventure and that they're capable of
learning enough as a consequence of moving
forward on the adventure so that they
straightened themselves out across time.
And so it's something like this,
and this circumambulation that young
talked about was this continual,
we'll return to this,
this continual circling in
some sense of who you could be.
You might notice,
for example,
that there are themes in your life.
You know,
when you go back across your experiences,
you see,
you kind of have your typical
experience that sort of repeats itself.
And there might be on
it like a musical theme,
but it's,
it's like you're,
you're circling yourself and
getting closer to yourself
as you move across time.
That's the circumambulation now you
remember that for a second cause we'll go
back to it.
Okay.
So imagine that something
glimmers before you,
it's an interest that's
daunting and you decide,
well,
first of all,
you're paralyzed.
You think,
well how do I know if
I should pursue that?
It's probably a stupid idea.
And the proper response to that is,
you're right,
it probably is a stupid
idea because almost all,
all ideas are stupid.
And so the probability that as you move
forward on your adventure that you're
going to get it right
the first time is zero.
It's just not going to happen.
And so then you might think,
well maybe I'll just wait around
until I get the right idea.
And which people do,
right?
So they're like 40 year old,
13 year olds,
which is not a good idea.
So they wait around until it's waiting
for Godot until they finally got it
right.
But the problem is you're too stupid
to know when you've got it right.
So waiting around isn't going to
help because even if it's the perfect
opportunity manifested itself
to you in your incomplete form,
the probability that you would recognize
it as the perfect opportunity is zero.
You might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere.
Highly likely,
highly likely.
So,
so you ha there's niche
nichier called that.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll to stupidity,
which I really liked.
So because he thought of
stupidity as being it,
you know,
it's,
you have to take it into account
fundamentally and work with it.
And so,
and so you can take these tentative steps
on your pathway to destiny and you can
assume that you're going to do it badly.
And that's really useful because
you don't have to beat yourself up.
It's pretty easy to do it badly.
But the thing is,
it's way better to do it badly
than not to do it at all.
And that's the continual message that
echoes through these historical stories in
genesis.
It's like these are flawed people.
They should've got the hell out of
their house way before they did.
Um,
and they go out and they stumble around
in tyranny and famine and self betrayal
and,
and violence.
And,
but it's a hell of a lot better
than just rotting away at home.